you're very welcome on the program
michael wolfer tell us first of all then
on that point do you think president
trump
will stay president trump an active
president for another four years or is
joe biden going to win out what's your
gut feeling
i um joe biden will be the next
president of the united states donald
trump will be
uh um history by i'd put it at
8 45 on um eastern time tuesday night
okay 3 45 a.m in the uk that's a
a pretty precise prediction let's ask
you for
any evidence if you've got some
well i i mean the numbers are
overwhelming um
matter of fact the idea that this is a
horse race is just um
a media thing um uh anybody who's
actually looking deeply into these
numbers is going
oh my god um it is um
it is almost impossible virtually
beyond the beyond the pale to imagine
that um
that donald trump could recover at this
at this point
but michael you know the the democrats
themselves are saying well we are
looking
at that polling the national lead which
doesn't of course as we know
necessarily lead to victory but the lead
in those key
states and some of them are pretty
similar to the lead that hillary clinton
held over donald trump at precisely the
same time in the campaign
so they're being much more cautious than
you it must be said
no well they're not being that cautious
i mean they may be cautious
they may be saying that to you and they
may be saying that for media consumption
but among themselves they are um
as confident as it is humanly possible
to be
could you give us a bit more sourcing on
that have you been speaking to those on
the inside
who are privy to their private polling
yeah
yeah and it's not it's not as if there
are a few people there are many many
many people i mean we're talking about
across the board on
on any political professional at this
point
um is looking at this and saying um
this is a once-in-a-generation um
um uh election in which there
there is no no question about what the
outcome is going to be the only question
of course is how big the
um uh the the margin will be
um okay even to the extent that you can
think it's a landslide
how big of a landslide and it may be the
biggest ever
as i say quite a prediction well let's
look at the trump campaign then because
as i say you
were on on the inside uh wrote two books
two best-selling books
about the trump white house and um two i
suppose
sum them up you described a chronically
chaotic and
dysfunctional white house and and
president have you seen
the trump campaign doing that on the
campaign trail itself as well
keeping that kind of message up leader
of
without without question remember they
have somehow this campaign
um uh raised and spent a billion dollars
long before it should have been
spent i mean it's a it's a complete um
uh you know yeah you know the the the
people in the campaign
are subpar professionals donald trump
who basically is running the campaign
um has no idea how to how to wage a
national race
has no idea how to administer something
that
is um granular data driven
all about um deep down in the weeds
um so i i mean even before the
coronavirus um uh hit i think
it was clear to anyone taking a close
look at this
that that the chances for a trump
re-election were remote
and it's part of that problem you
describe it in the books there this high
turnover of people of advisers whoever
it may be
senior officials as well if you don't
agree with the president
you don't last very long i mean even
since since you were there since you
were observing it all they've all
changed
100 actually 100 and 100 and then
another 100 percent
have uh have have cycled through this
this administration
and most of them to now be in the
position of saying
um um they are not voting for donald
trump and
many of them urging a vote for joe biden
and what off the handling of coronavirus
in terms well you know we go back to
january february the beginning
of the year and some of the the policies
that were put in place there in spite of
the fact that there
was a whole uh let's say uh a game plan
to deal with a pandemic left by yeah
i i mean i i don't think there's any
there's any question
incontrovertibly um the the president
has been
incompetent in his handling of the
coronavirus
um and um he may well have been
mendicious in his handling of the virus
how do you mean just uh expand on that
he says that he wanted to downplay it in
the
in the early stages i mean yes
i mean he told lies about it he has told
people you know don't
don't wear masks or has um has
downplayed
all of the things that almost everyone
agrees
are necessary to keep people safe so
he's put people
in danger and you don't have to be a
pollster do you to work out how
unpopular that is in in many parts
whether they be red or blue in the
united states
um the president he's doing it again
today i've heard him today he's sticking
to that line particularly since he
himself recovered from coronavirus that
that it's really not
too much to to worry about and and and
there you go
and therein lies the um uh the seeds of
and historic defeat
there's another um factor of the
campaign that is striking as well this
characterization
of joe biden as as daughtery as too old
when you've you've got a president who's
well only three and a bit years younger
than him
um and um i'm patently off his rocker um
at least in the estimation of of um
likely a significant majority of
american voters yes so that has not
worked out well no
none of the messaging here has worked
out very well
and if you've got any sense of knowing
and having actually that may be more
precise okay there really is no message
okay i mean but have you got any sense
of what happens after
this election whatever the result may be
given what donald trump's been saying
about the
the rigged nature of it how the mailing
ballots have been rigged against him
i mean what happens if he refuses to go
do you think he might
i i do not i think he will go i think
this will
uh revert to the mean i mean he will
bluster
and um and shout and
stamp his feet um but
but in in the end remember the man has a
very
very short attention span um so he will
be on to the next thing
very quickly